(HABLA INGLIS)
INGLIS) (HABLA HABLA EN INGLIS)
(HABLA EN INGLIS) (HABLA EN
INGLIS) (HABLA (HABLA EN
ALSO HAD A LOT OF MEANINGFUL
RODRIGUES REBOUND, AND THE PUCK
IS JUST GOING BLOCKED BY NIC DO.
BLUEGER TRYING TO PLAY ITON.
AS HE GETS IN ON THE FORECHECK
SHOT HIM BY THE BALL.
CROSBY, FOR D
A NICE PAST SAVE AS
GOING
TURNAROUND SHOT KICKED OUT.
PL
AND HIGHTED BY THE POWER PLAY G
AND TYING IT AT THREE.
!OF HIS
STICK.
IT IS SO LOUD THE ZONA.
AT THE
THAT WAS BACK IN JANUARY.
HAVE
THEY A
ORIGINALLY FROM SLZUCKER.
MALKIN BATTED IS
WILSON SCORES.
BEAUTIFUL WRIST SHOT IN THE TOP
BULLET, AS HE BEATS TRISTAN
JARRY UP
THEY HAVE TAKEN A 4-3 LEAD.
TOO MANY MEN AGAINST PITTSBURGH
DO TOO MUCH.
KUZNETSOV, AT THE EMPTY NET, AND
THE GOAL OFF THE
POST OFF THE ONE-TIMER FROM
LETANG.
LETANG
PENALTY HAS EXPIRED. THEN
STARTED TO TAKE THE GAME OVER.
TOM WILSON'S GOING CLEAR THIS